[Music]
as a child renee
you made us both realise you had a
spirit and determination in you like no
other
we knew
that we wouldn't have to worry about you
achieving
whatever you put your mind to
[Music]
add a child david was everything we
could have asked for
and nothing has actually changed
we couldn't be prouder of the man that
he has grown into
[Music]
when a young man
is as well-mannered
consider it
caring
and spoils his girl like david
you know he has come from a beautiful
loving family
[Music]
david and renee
we want you to know that we will always
be there for you
we want you to take good care
of each other
and always respect and support one
another
[Music]
renee
a decade ago without a moment's notice
you confidently turned around with your
piercing blue eyes
and changed my life forever
what was meant to be a typical
orientation day turned into the best day
of my life
as you turned around
the entire world faded away
[Music]
i blindly followed you that entire day
as i felt overwhelming unexplainable
emotions
it was your childlike excitement for
life
your genuine love and compassion for
people
and your dedication for what you
believed in that made me feel certain
around you
[Music]
not only were you this beautiful
confident person that turned into my
life
but you also changed it forever
david
[Music]
i remember that feeling i had back in
2012
a feeling of connection
whether it's the small gestures
like
asking me if i want a massage every
night before bed
[Music]
or the big gestures
like your elaborate six-month proposal
you make me
feel prioritized
safe
empowered
and inordinately proud to be by your
side
[Music]
thank you for choosing me
i love you
[Music]